взагалі не хочу їхати щирі ложки
вона
вам полтавські наложкою як правоту вати
московську ковбаску тореза ти
тут я голом як
можна пиво літрами
топики для потім за брами і вуд не
викликали ти можеш іконка наш українською
стукіт досяг сукні а я таким begin і
займаюсь забирай кумедно води та
льоду криму добу може завтра
страшна
і хто не знає, що там сталося
але що реально сталося, що там
все-таки сталося що сталося що
сталося, що відбувається, що сталося
що ж відбувається і сьогодні сталося
щось там серйозне відбувається те, що
сталося ми не знаємо
[оплески]
[музика]
баумана і ось вид вібрація пішла
зараз це
хвилював натиснувши прийдуть до не боюся
розгадав
[музика]
шеннон то копита не їж від такої обидва
чому на всіх українських каналів
скрізь написано богів на криму
балонів донецького бо вона там щебет я
розумію ми радянські учні напевно
щось там десь не до вчили але навіть я
знаю і пам'ятаю що богуна за бавовну і
рада та землі
займаючи новий район
ми тут не до чого зовсім не розумію
боїмося почем а ми тут ні до чого а ми
тут не до чого танцем веселимось
ну гаразд ми бомбимо україну з криму ну
навіщо бомбити води звинувачують дайте мені відповідь
тільки сьогодні обговорювали тему про те, що
101 вичавити з криму я говорю але в
принцип до останнього як би можна
потерпіти але коли коли [ __ ] ти бачиш
як над головою
йібан
просто подивіться
це просто [ __ ] просто пряме
включення нахуй через йорку зараз поки
думки млинець що треба
валити з криму чуєш, а ось цю ранку
донат та лікарі в крипто валюту за силу а
таке
так джон coin
[музика]
наші умови проведення референдуму ваша
повна капітуляція визнання лнр днр
хана за мир і все, що кінчається на ви
змушені будете провести
демілітаризації одиниці фікації
дебілізація населення на користь називати
війну спецоперації вибухи бавовнами
криза та імпортозаміщення та повернути
макдональд і платити за біг мак у рублях
цілях пацани
хлопці бруд та
тикун і зустрічей давайте але будь з
оточення чи я його вб'ю так мені [ __ ]
телебачення наші покаже, що це ваш
такий так нам нас рота на коня чи ну
ну ну ну ну добре ви не боїтеся що ми
можемо вдарити я der кайфувати та не
боїшся ж ми можемо put-обидві в дар і ти
пити компу лобі але все за
духу маса пенс
ви homo sapiens
російська
[оплески]
душ туалет біля моєї душі немає в туалет
так є
банки тобто наполягти чи від унітазу
багато в тебе нікого немає, а які звичайні
звичайна на вулиці з діркою ми з збитий
з ви ви не приймете будинку туалету в будинку
туалет що він взагалі в принципі у дворі
існує одяг в будинку будинку немає хто
мене ці ось вам би коштувало по собі в
будинку зробити туалети і душ а от у
вас проблем на ви приїхали в україну вам
вже все готове вдома каналізації б
провели нарешті
тому що ось в Індії наприклад там у
п'ятому столітті до нашої ери на мою вони вже
з'явились
точно можу помилятися контролю дуже
давно але зараз 2022 а у вас вдома
унітазу немає розумієте і навіть би так
добре скажіть будь ласка, а ось ви про
зарплату цікавитеся вже знизили
зарплату а як ви ставитеся до того, що
у нас тут люди гинуть та їх вбивають
російські солдати
таки бандерас кордон чому і так
називають підтримувати рух
бандерівців такі бандерівці українки
чому їх так називають що не
підтримуються руху бандерасу як
думаю що причина конфлікту Росії та
україни тому що цього президента
посадили українці лапка що так що
неправильно судновий чому з колії
людина і квінсі хто її ну що і
нерозумний я десь простую цю людину
добрий жар туяна два роди це свідчення
до того, що його добрий інтелект були
інші кандидатури на пост президента
для вас те зростання який був а хто був
лукашенко і розумів а і вони тут і
наклеп якийсь нові історії у російської
федерації кошенка як би визнати
Україна була правильної політики щодо
принаймні до цього воїна не було
таких серйозних навчався чому лукашенко
пішов з посади україна спа президент
українці закінчився пішов і чим зараз
займається лукашенком не знаю не
цікаве життя це крок залишився прийде
у цьому залі сьогодні присутній
відомі воєначальники
дружніх нам держав бурунді
гвінейської республіки камерун о'маллі
судана
уганди чада ефіопії
південно-африканській республіці ми цінуємо
вашу підтримку
по-перше я історик а тут
справжній дипломат був інструктором
політвідділу я хороший спортсмен з
багатьом видам спорту в мене були
деякі здібності я Дмитрий
прикордонник я написав
україни я паралельно закінчував школу
лекторів я тоді якийсь час суспільство
знання очолював я міжнародник am
завжди будуть я працював у сільському
господарстві директором я постійно в
церква кожен професійний
футболіст ви маєте справу з фотографом
радянських я побував у всіх військах ви
знаєте, що вас дівчата дуже люблять
про це кажуть деяким чином
спеціаліст з агентом
олексій розкажіть про свої досяти мене
мертвим і рибалив і я вбив а зараз
чорним морем по чорній стіні і викуплю
скрипт у все і піднятися вище за нього
арешту 308 дивом світу
три години через горбачовий Михайло
Сергійовичем на шашлику так їх тепер з
вами я шафер я столяр я художник явно
хімік я конструктор ну все багато пішов.
та 17 для театру та 28 років в армії та в
психології 30 років і тоді ви там в одну
точку зійшлося з ігор alawar і продовжує
грати та
олімпіада почалася китайці сказали ні
потім ці стрічки анімації олімпіаду так
потім не перебивайте потім закриття
олімпіади потім 22 має брати але це
20 як називайте нове інтерв'ю у роті
над орестовичем а два нарциси на мій або
української журналістики це дух сексом
as if людини за лаги росія
дорогий щоденник
звучать вже були вбиті кімнаті значить
система
дає наприклад на фразу яко розкриваючи
собі їх не все parse.com від у нас я
пом'ята касета допомагали на частини видно
з соткою з магазину до будинку іваном і не
кожен модуль чокнутої пунктом 2 ви
такий добрий можемо цієї бог вам
здоров'я дай боже щоб усі такі були у
нас ніби як ви але такий гарний
хлопчик цей я кажу а давайте україна
мені здається значить хлопчик
так якщо я все життя в цьому місті
прожила і все життя тут на своєму
рідною російською мовою милі так якого я
повинна говорити на вашому
українця та якщо взагалі слова
я взагалі
Російської Федерації
по бенді
[музика]
[оплески]
ще сто років тому так розмовляли всі
жителя кубані заперечити балочку
офіційна мова кубанських козаків
намагаються в краснодарському краї Сергій
пікулін намагався зрозуміти про що вони говорять
з першого погляду кубанської звуку нічим
не відрізняється від загальновизнаної букви ті
ж їхня кількість теж але проблема в тому
що слів знайомих немає ось наприклад
літера й у російському букварі на неї одне
слово j про це знає кожен школяр
в кубанської абетки слів на цю букву 10
до 6 годин
sd
є такі слова звичайно
у тебе це означає йде їсти це значить
їсти дзвонила мама сказала що
сьогодні медовий врятував а я і сказав мама
на медовий врятував медовий а це вам
сайту людожер видавництво послала увійти
українську я кіно народилася в такому і
садовий рахунок широких батьків чайки
західної України в мани за раз даних
адже мало не буду худий вид природи
дівчата та
кине шаблон дрова роботи щоб так
водою
ти такий
сидиш на дієті with російських
злилий поблизу рвалися а далі в міфі
ти туди of cute худи дівчини вітчизною ти
людожер якщо вич навчальних планів виходи а
самі такі і тироксину в шпиль
чекає на вигляд ось це вібро своїм or і не
дошка
податки на
розум і виходьте по ходу божий кий моєму
на годину свитанок і
готелю дим вони схожі на ходу дівчину і
кого так ось тут кира живиці без браян
форматі ще 10, а може видно в цю
роботу в україні та багато українців
щупача але робота я хочу макдональдс
power to its а значить у церкві та на
закінчиться
[музика]
а я чика
знижки треба
тільки ти міг
[музика]
вийшов на 5 kobayashi k 2
вже за
струмок
[музика]
ми купили супутник бо хвилі буде баготу
[оплески]
hotel але змінюватися проколом дівчина я як
вони бігають метушаться задоволені там криму
класний фільм грунт я взагалі не хочу
їхати а
зрадити самого їх одну бабакан росію
спонсор вашої страшної
вже
алла для вас булла cc в будівлі разів хоста
їй раз мамуля мамуля звали звідси
1 п'яний до мене купатися для спаси ти
жила півки.
[музика]
запам'ятають рай і на ганку rus і на
березі берді ланцюга після нашої ери до
гнучкіша
а ти смузі руди
щоб посмішка, звідки вона буде as your age
відсікаємо на списку бен і
пукіна ми нарізно
російською всіх ми пружини
м україна російська кручена нову еру стригти
ну а потім я пить і
вигляд буду емсі міст і
і запала з нас
кохання а через місяць стрибати з ніг по
бабам по пандеміям авеста
па-па-па-па пандемій та тато
тато не заважати, а просто нлп
[музика]